la présidente du front national marine
le pen est l'invitée de preuves par 3
bonsoir ça et merci d'être avec nous
après les élections départementales qui
traduit un bouleversement politique avec
la forte progression du fn selon le
constat dressé entre autres par manuel
valls
ça vous fait au moins un point commun un
point d'accord avec le premier ministre
ou un preuve par 3 en association bien
sûr comme chaque semaine avec l' agence
france-presse représenter ce soir par
guillaume duden avec dailymotion
également et bien sûr avec perrine
tarneaud de public sénat au surlendemain
de son échec électoral manuel valls est
resté à paris ce mardi face aux députés
plutôt d'aller à berlin où s'est rendu
françois hollande pour un conseil des
ministres franco-allemand le chef de
l'état a confirmé le cap des réformes il
sera maintenu et le premier ministre
donc devant l'assemblée national marine
le pen a été très clair pas de
changement de politique mais son
amplification en faveur de
l'investissement des entreprises pas de
remaniement pas d'émission qu'avez vous
envie de souhaiter au premier ministre
un an pile après son arrivée à matignon
alors d'abord je remarque le président
de la république à chaque fois qui perd
une élection il file à berlin pourrait
se justifier auprès de madame merkel
comme pas très rassurant ça confirme ce
que nous disons à savoir qu' il est en
fait un sous-préfet de l'union
européenne et il va donc chercher ses
ordres ou se faire taper sur les doigts
ou exprimé auprès de madame merkel le
fait que malgré les résultats des
élections
c'est très révélateur sur le plan du
fonctionnement de la démocratie malgré
les résultats des élections et bien il
continuera la feuille de route que lui a
donnée l'union européenne et ce de la
manière la plus serviles qui soit vous
imaginez bien que moi qui suis attaché à
la souveraineté de la france
ceci me déplaît absolument profondément
rien d'étonnant à ce que manuel valls
annonce qu'il va continuer sur la même
voie il l'avait dit avant même le
résultat bon donc les français ont le
sentiment que ce sont des élections pour
rien puisque quoiqu'il dise quoi qu'ils
expriment par leur vote est bien le
gouvernement continue de manière
rectiligne a envoyé la france dans le
mur puisque c'est la politique
d'austérité nous avions annoncé au front
national qui après macouin huret macron
de cabrières à mâcon 3 eh bien voyez
macron 2
pas le bout de son nez mais vous ne
souhaitez pas ou moins que manuel valls
disent vrai quand elle dit que la
reprise est là qu il ya des signes
positifs nous écouter ça fait deux ans
et demi qu'on nous raconte cette
fariboles ça va arrêter et encore je
suis gentil est ce que nicolas sarkozy
nous faisait la même chose avec madame
lagarde vous souvenez pas madame lagarde
tous les six mois l arrivée en dix ans
la crise est derrière nous tous les six
mois et tous les six mois la crise
s'aggravait et elle revenait
imperturbablement pour dire la crise est
derrière nous mais j'ai géré pendant
combien d'années ils vont nous prendre
comme ça pour des enfants
évidemment que la crise est là le
chômage est massif
il continue d'augmenter et il n'y a
absolument aucun signe de reprise les
petits frétillement d'ailleurs qui
existent ne sont pas liées à la
politique du gouvernement
on est témoin france pour en profiter
non mais d'accord ok très bien mais ça
n'a aucune relation avec la politique
mise en oeuvre par le gouvernement la
peau scellier scellier à la baisse de
haut niveau de l'euro tient je remarque
que la baisse du niveau de l'euro tout
le monde s'en félicite comme ce n'est
pas marine le pen qui la proposent mais
sans arrogance mais répète aujourd'hui
qu'il l'avait réclamé également à fait
d'accord donc quand moi je demandais une
dévaluation
c'était épouvantable sa lettre le chaos
mais quand eux ils demandent une
dévaluation et bien c'est merveilleux ça
apporte des points positifs non mais je
le note bon c'est lié à la politique de
planche à billets de l'union européenne
dont je rappelle que quand je la
proposerai quand je proposais pour la
france de la création monétaire
on m'expliquer que ça allait être aussi
au niveau européen ça ne crée pas mais
je consens salon européen non non c'est
non je vais vous expliquer pourquoi mais
non ça n'est pas la politique qu'il faut
mener car la réalité c'est que cette
planche à billets elle sert en réalité à
renflouer les banques et non pas à aider
les relancer l'économie réelle
et puis troisièmement la baisse du
pétrole la baisse du prix du pétrole
donc tout cela n'a strictement rien à
voir avec une action positive de la part
du gouvernement et par conséquent il n'y
a qu'à hélas s'attendre à une
aggravation de l'austérité qui elle en
revanche continue sur une belle lancée
alors néanmoins donc manuel valls
propose d'amplifier certaines réformes
vous l'avez entendu il mise par exemple
sur des plans d'investissements massifs
d'ordre privé d'ordre public également
il a annoncé les dents délais
en d ça ne dépend pas de nuit si vous
voulez il fait les promesses en disant
je vous promets que avec le portefeuille
de l'autre je vais vous donner de
l'argent mais ils n'en savent rien c'est
exactement l'opération qui a été menée
par l'union européenne en disant nous on
va mettre quelques milliards et vous
allez voir le privé va se précipiter
pour investir
attendons de voir quand même permettez
moi de ne pas les croire sur parole car
je suis pas sûr que les investisseurs
privés aujourd'hui il est très envie
d'investir massivement compte tenu du
fait que eux ils sont quand même
conscient que précisément la crise dans
l'infini il s'agit d un site et
notamment sur le plan fiscal
on verra le détail des mesures
lorsqu'elles seront exposés marine le
pen le premier ministre mise aussi sur
des embauches facilité dans les pme qui
aurait alors la possibilité de licencier
plus facilement que pensez vous de cette
deuxième piste de recherche en faveur de
l'emploi non mais attendez la facilité
de licencier les gens ça crée pas de
l'emploi excusez-moi pas ou alors faut
m'expliquer comment ça marche bien le
fait de pouvoir licencier plus
facilement ça va créer les patrons de
pme disent que ça nous permettra
d'embaucher plus facilement si on veut
se séparer des salariés en cas de
difficultés économiques c'est l'heure
d'un secours
arrêtez jamais aucune loi n'a été fait
pour les pme ça c'est l'enrobage du
paquet cadeau
la réalité c'est que ces lois là elles
sont faites pour les grands groupes et
qu'est ce que ça va être facile pour un
grand groupe de dire ah bah vous voyez
ma filière là elle perd de l'argent
alors il faut que je licencie
massivement parce qu'entre temps il aura
transféré ses bénéfices dans une autre
filière peut-être même dans un autre
pays
vous le savez parfaitement donc ça c'est
fait pour les grands groupes c'est pas
fait pour les pme et encore une fois on
gère la pénurie mais où est-ce qu'on
crée de l'emploi avec ces mesures là il
n'y a pas de création d'emplois car pour
créer de l'emploi il faut radicalement
changer le modèle économique et il faut
tourner le dos à la politique
d'austérité qui va s'accélérer car c'est
l'objectif de la loi macron et nous
sommes là d'ailleurs dans cette loi là
dans les annonces de monsieur vas tu
exactement comme par hasard dans ce que
réclame l'union européenne c'est drôle
c'est exactement ce qu'ils ont avec la
main à la grèce aussi voyez donc et on
voit ce que ça a donné pour la grèce car
la situation ta gueule et on en parlera
plus tard mais en vain
l'action du nouveau au beau voyons
voyons ils sont là depuis trois mois
c'est eux qui vont être responsable de
la baisse de 25% des salaires c'est eux
qui vont être responsable des 60 % de
chômage chez les jeunes
faut quand même être un petit peu juste
et honnête la réalité c'est que la
situation de la grèce aujourd'hui est
exclusivement de la responsabilité de
lugnorre laura et de la troïka qui ont
imposé à ce pays une cure d'austérité
massive qui a arrêté l'économie arrêté
l'économie et précipité le peuple grec
dans une souffrance inouïe alors on
reviendra sur la situation de la grèce
aujourd'hui tout à l'heure dans la
dernière partie de l'émission avec
perrine tarneaud si vous êtes d'accord
un mot peut-être sur le plan social qui
s'annonce aujourd'hui en tous les cas la
décision de justice la liquidation du
transporteur maury global avec deux
mille cent cinquante salariés qui se
retrouvent sur le sur le carreau le
gouvernement les pouvoirs publics
s'étaient portés au secours de
l'actionnaire qui manifestement là a été
défaillant que feriez-vous face à cette
situation je les protégerait de la
concurrence internationale déloyale
saissac laitue d'accord c'est ça qui tue
les transporteurs c'est la concurrence
internationale déloyale
c'est se retrouver en concurrence avec
des entreprises qui utilisent des dires
des conducteurs qui n'ont absolument pas
les mêmes normes sociales qui n'ont
absolument pas les mêmes temps de
travail est évidemment confrontés à cela
et bien les entreprises de transport
français ne peuvent pas lutter contre
ces ragots sont parfois internationaux
entreprises françaises légales vont
embaucher à l'étrange mais ils ne
peuvent pas faire autrement monsieur car
pour être compétitif on les force à
faire cela c'est exactement comme quand
on a mis en place la directive
détachement des travailleurs
quand une entreprise d'un secteur
utilisent des travailleurs détachés les
autres entreprises sont obligées aussi
de le faire car sinon et bien elles sont
elles n'ont plus qu'à fermer boutique
donc le gouvernement avec cette
directive détachement des travailleurs
organise une préférence étrangère à
l'emploi puisque le travailleur étranger
coûtant moins cher c'est lui qui passe
en premier et de surcroît il oblige en
quelque sorte les entreprises qui
voudraient faire du patriotisme
économique a précisément à les embaucher
à l'étranger je veux dire
alors quoi manuel valls se montre
constant dans son combat son combat
contre vous vous l'aurez entendu contre
le front national ou non il l'a répété
devant l'assemblée nationale
au nom des valeurs de la république
marie le pen il prévient c'est bien
c'est joli continuerai il vous a donc
identifié comme le péril numéro 1 en
seulement 10 1 pouces alors je sais pas
le fondamentalisme islamiste que perry
numéro à non c'est pas le terrorisme
c'est pas parce que le front national
lui il a fait de mal à personne
il est ni responsable évoque les valeurs
des compagnies responsables d'été du
terrorisme ni responsable du chômage les
responsables de l'insécurité il
responsable de la dette ni du déficit et
cetera et cetera
quelle valeur de la public il dit
notamment que le pays est trop divisée
trop fractures elle nous est d'abord si
qu'elle va d'accord avec ce constat
comment il se remarque une chose c'est
que je vais sur des plateaux de
télévision je vois des journalistes
répéter comme des perroquets ce que
racontent les uns et les autres îles
d'hyères c'est toujours la même chose et
les valeurs de la république et vert de
la public j'ai pas vu un journaliste a
reposé la question clé qu'elle lesquels
précisément monsieur val di fassa est
antirépublicain précisément pourquoi
mais il a fait qu'elles sont les règnes
de bessan les valeurs au dessus d'un
média comme et on angoisse est d'accord
mais personne ne lui pose la question
ça ce sont ce sont des paroles verbales
les contres les valeurs d'abus lesquels
moi je tiens que le front national est
celui qui précisément non seulement
respectent le plus les valeurs de la
république cherche à imposer à la classe
politique le respect des valeurs de
l'edf va continuer le combat sur ce
thème là oui mais d'accord mais parce
qu'il n'a rien d'autre à dire permettez
moi quand on peut pas défendre son
propre bilan tellement il est mauvais
tellement il est nul
eh bien il faut bien essayer de
détourner l'attention alors on détourne
l'attention en luttant la vieille bonne
méthode qu'on connaît depuis des
décennies contre le front national qui
est accusé de tous les maux qui est
parée de tous les défauts et qui encore
une fois est accusé d'être un danger
mais un danger pour qui à part pour eux
à part pour cette classe politique qui a
peur du grand remplacement mais du grand
remplacement de la classe politique
le front national vous parlait pas des
immigrés le grand emplacement non non je
parle du grand place du grand
remplacement de la classe politique par
le front national représentant du peuple
français alors dans les critiques qui
visent le front national et il ya celles
du célèbre couple serge et béate
klarsfeld est le célèbre avocat chasseur
de nazis qui annonce d'ailleurs qu'il
quittera la france si vous êtes élu et
il vous voit porter un fascisme à la
française alors qu'une que l'ambiance
est bien entendu dire que l'arrivée au
pouvoir de marine le pen serait la
destruction de la mémoire de la shoah
mais sérieusement mais c'est délirant
quoi je te dire c'est complètement
délirant c'est quoi c'est ça l'acce
d'attac pour les quelques mois qui vont
nous séparer de la présidentielle c'est
mettre une machine moustache ça va être
ça la kz d'attac
mais j'ai géré ccc en même temps
pitoyable dérisoire grotesque et
objectivement à ces dates il faut dire
par rapport à bas par rapport à
l'histoire de votre part non mais par
rapport à 2002 on a déjà fait ça je veux
dire encore une fois enfin on va
recommencer moi je vous rappelle les
propos de monsieur j'ose pas après 2002
qui avait dit mais enfin écoutez il ya
jamais eu de danger fasciste qu'en
france le front national n'a jamais été
un mouvement fasciste tout ça c'est du
théâtre disait lionel jospin
voilà ancien premier ministre tout ça
c'est du théâtre
eh bien ils continuent comme des mauvais
acteur l'on fera jouer de ses rejetons
oui mais je vis de lui mais si je parle
d'eux
je parle de de l'ump je parle du parti
socialiste ce sont des vieux acteurs qui
jouent qui rejouent et qui rejoue une
pièce de théâtre il n'a plus de
spectateurs
c'est en quelques secondes encore sur le
couple de serge et béate klarsfeld qui
ont pourchassé toute leur vie durant
les anciens nazis et qui publie ces
jours-ci leur mémoire
il ya peut-être une incompréhension mais
nous avons du fait d'être nés par
d'exprimer peut-être votre admiration
pour ce qu'ils ont fait dans leurs
lycées pardon je ne vais exprimer aucune
admiration pour des gens qui m'accusent
mois 1/2 vouloir détruire la mémoire de
la shoah mais je suis né en 68 monsieur
qu'est ce que c'est que ces cinémas
que dire qu'est ce que c'est que ce
cinéma
alors moi je suis scandalisé par ce type
de déclaration scandalisé voilà je
trouve que c'est indigne a dit non
seulement vis-à-vis de moi
ce qui serait somme toute pas très grave
indigne vis-à-vis des millions
d'électeurs français qui votent pour le
front national des 25% des électeurs
français qui votent pour le front
national
on va revenir sur le calendrier
électoral si vous le voulez bien après
les départementales les régionales
et puis bien sûr la présidentielle vous
n'avez pas décroché d'exécutif dimanche
dernier mais vos est lui-même en nombre
limité vous donne évidemment plus
d'ancrage territorial c'était l'un de
vos objectifs
comme le montrent les enquêtes de marib
remo avant d'accueillir notre confrère
de la sp guillaume daudin aucun doute
avec ces élections départementales le
front national confirme son implantation
locale en phase ascendante depuis le
milieu du quinquennat sarkozy
il était capable de présenter des
candidats dont quasiment l'intégralité
des cantons et ensuite parce qu'au
premier tour
il a reçu plus de 20 5% des suffrages
alors que la plus grande partie de ces
candidats était nouveau et inconnu des
électeurs et dans toutes les villes
qu'il dirige le fn progresse par rapport
au premier tour des élections
municipales de 2014
à fréjus et au pontet de villes tombées
dans l'escarcelle du front national il y
a un an
les binômes fn ont même été élu dès le
premier tour
et si au final le front national ne
remporte que 31 cantons le parti compte
désormais 62 conseillers départementaux
au lieu d'un seul
en plus des 1600 conseillers municipaux
et des 118 conseillers régionaux actuels
ce dernier chiffre pourrait bien
fortement grossir lors des futures
élections régionales de décembre
prochain avec un mode de scrutin plus
favorables au fn et on se rend compte qu
à la fois en nord-pas-de-calais picardie
et en paca le front national pourrait
obtenir jusqu'à 35% des suffrages ce qui
le mettra en position de diriger ces
deux régions en effet il suffit d'avoir
33 % dans un contexte de triangulaire au
second tour pour diriger l'une et
l'autre de ces régions d'autres
conquêtes local éventuel en perspective
qui confirme la volonté du parti
d'amplifier son maillage territorial et
si on est bien loin des baronnies
locales qui existe dans d'autres partis
l'enracinement apparaît nécessaire mais
c'est aussi surtout de professionnaliser
l'appareil partisans du front national
parce que aujourd'hui si vous voulez
avoir des gens qui sont des permanents
dans le parti qui travaille pour un pour
le parti etc
compte tenu des budgets des partis
politiques français
vous pouvez pas payer beaucoup de
permanent avec le financement public de
la vie électorale donc par quoi ça passe
la construction d'un appareil partisan
ça passe par les postes d'élus et les
collaborateurs qui vont avec des élus
locaux un enjeu financier donc et
surtout des relais une vitrine pour la
grande conquête du fn et de sa
présidente
l'élection présidentielle de 2017 pour
faire de la fp spécialiste de ces
questions nous on lutte contre le
chômage 1 je peux vous dire qu'avec le
boulot qu'on a filé au spécialiste de
l'extrême droite ou du front national là
vous avez des emplois il ya des emplois
qu'ils ont rempli un vous avez publié ce
matin la charte du fn pour des alliances
au second tour
donc vous reprenez assez largement votre
programme et vous proposer à des élus
dans les départements de l'assigner en
échange des voix du fn pour la
présidence du département
est ce que ça peut marcher dans quel
département
dans le gard dans le vaucluse c'est à
dire c'est proposer évidemment dans des
départements où il n'y a pas de majorité
bien sûr et où les l'apport des voix des
élus front national peut faire basculer
la majorité d'un côté ou de l'autre mais
nous faisons cela sans contrepartie
que les choses soient claires nous
sommes pas là dans les manoeuvres
d'appareil
tu me donnes une vice présidence et je
vote pour toi nous sommes là pour faire
respecter la volonté de nos électeurs
nos secteurs ils ont voté pour nous pour
nous défendre un programme nous disons à
ceux qui éventuellement seraient
intéressés par un soutien nous voulons
bien vous soutenir mais la contrepartie
c'est pas des postes
il déplace c'est que vous mettiez en
oeuvre l'engagement de ne pas augmenter
les impôts l'engagement de lutter contre
le communautarisme l'engagement
d'interdire le voile dans les crèches
etc
mais nicolas sarkozy a déjà prévenu que
toute alliance avec le fn voudrait
exclusion
donc sa part r c'est très bien alors
donc donc dans le gard l'ump par exemple
va offrir le département à la gauche par
la normale que l'ump gouverne avec mais
non mais dans ces cas là il faut pas
dire partout sur tous les plateaux
oui le fn ps est votée france est assez
voter ps non là pour le coup voter ump
c'est voter ps
mais tant mieux ça ça moi tout ce qui
contribue si vous voulez à clarifier la
réalité de ce qu'est l'ump s va plutôt
dans le bon sens parce que je sais qu'il
ya encore des électeurs qui pensent que
l'ump est fait et défend un projet
différent de celui du parti socialiste
tout événement qui vient leur expliquer
la réalité à savoir que non ils mènent
exactement le même programme est qu
après tout que ce soit les uns ou les
autres avec dérange pas trop
mais dans les départements ils vous
paraîtrait plus normal que les élus fn
gouverne avec des élus de droite
non mais moi si ici les socialistes
viennent me dire que ils refusent
d'augmenter les impôts qui refusent le
communautarisme qui refusent le voilà
les dents dans la crèche qui vont lutter
pour défendre les services publics de
proximité etc etc
eh bien écoutez nous réfléchirons à
leurs propositions le tout c'est qu'ils
s'engagent encore une fois sur les
éléments essentiels de notre projet
d'accord vous vous réunissez au premier
tour départemental 25% des voix
c'est le meilleur score de l'histoire du
fn vous êtes en tête dans 43
départements et au final vous avez 5 %
des élus remporté 1,5 pour cent des
cancers c'est la démocratie française
mais est-ce que c'est pas un peu un
échec justement de la manière dont le
front national se positionne dans la vie
politique française
ah bon c'est un échec donc en fait on a
en a grand mais 1,5 pour cent des élus
au final est-ce que c'est par un échec
c'est l'échec de la démocratie c'est
l'échec démocratie qui fait que 25% des
électeurs français ne sont pas
représentés dans des proportions qui
soit digne
à défaut d'être égalitaire si vous
voulez c'est un vrai problème c'est un
vrai souci ça fait des décennies que ça
dure et c'est ce qui contribue à créer
ce gouffre entre le peuple français et
ses représentants tout simplement parce
que les représentants n'en sont pas
nouveaux le deed ce vous même ça fait
des décennies que ça dure donc à un
moment donné est ce que le la stratégie
du fn ne devrait pas être de faire des
alliances pour pouvoir plutôt que
d'avoir des en plus d'avoir des bons
scores en plus gouverner et donc
accédez à des émissions plus on avait
d'abord pardon nous avons quand même
gagné des villes non seulement dans ces
villes d'ailleurs les 10
les résultats ont été un véritable
plébiscite est bon puisque lé dans les
premiers tours des élections
départementales les scores et même dans
les deuxièmes d'ailleurs dans le
deuxième les scores qui ont été
effectués dans les villes front national
démontre que la population est
extrêmement satisfaits de la gestion des
villes donc nous avons gagné des villes
nous avons gagné des cantons nous en
avons nous avons 62 élus n'ont rappelé
là où nous en avions un bon on est passé
de 1 à 60 de ces camps mais 62 sur 4162
sur 4100 je suis bien d'accord avec vous
et je vous enjoins d'ailleurs peut-être
à regarder les résultats dans certains
départements le front national fait 40 %
parfois 15 points devant ses adversaires
il a zéro élus qui les ont pendant 12 ou
14 cantons alors c'est le profondément
scandaleux et c'est même du front
national mais moi je vais pas me vendre
pour un plat de lentilles je ne vais
sûrement pas m'allier avec des gens qui
mènent une politique radicalement
différente de celle que je veux voir
menées à à ce moment là je ne sers à
rien je veux dire il ya toute une série
de gens à l'ump au ps qui passent leur
vie à appeler à voter les uns pour les
autres à se désister les uns pour les
autres c'est déjà il ya déjà un parc
public de ce côté-là bon je suis là pour
proposer une si vous avez d'autres
élections qui s'annoncent avec un
scrutin un mode de scrutin qui vous est
plus favorable les régionales vous avez
parlé de pouvoir gagner dans quatre ou
cinq régions
donc si le nord pas de calais picardie
ou là vous allez peut-être vous avez
fait des très bons scores je crois que
c'est de l'ordre de 34 % il ya la paca
vous avez fait 33 % donc ça va être
scellé départements les plus accessibles
vous avez fait le calcul oui si vous
voulez le mode de scrutin des régionales
est un modus creed est radicalement
différent de celui des départementales
c'est celui qui arrive en tête au second
tour qui gagne la région voilà ce si
simple que cela
donc nous allons probablement évidemment
nous retrouver en triangulaire
donc il n'y a pas cinquante possibilité
pour l'ump est ce soit il se retire l'un
se retire au bénéfice de l'autre et il
disparaît totalement de la région
pendant six ans
soit il fusionne les listes ump est sain
c'est ce que monsieur lecerf de l'ump a
proposé d'ores et déjà dans le nord il a
proposé de présenter une liste commune
ump s il dit d'ailleurs que madame aubry
serait d'accord bon donc vous voyez que
tout va pour le mieux dans le meilleur
des mondes
soit ils appellent à est éliminé et il
appelle à voter les ou sol et se
maintiennent oui et que trois
possibilités vont gagner
bien sûr nous pouvons gagner et parce
que nous sommes dans beaucoup de
départements les plus forts et vous avez
été jusqu'à dire que même dans midi
pyrénées languedoc roussillon de la
victoire si vous êtes arrivés en tête
or nous sommes arrivés en tête le bloc
de gauche on est d'accord qu'ils vont
pas forcément s'unir parfaitement mais
le bloc de gauche parle dans cette
région fait presque 20 points de plus
que le fn
eh bien nous verrons nous verrons et
pour les départementales vous ne faisiez
aucun pronostic
là dessus on est d'accord vous en faites
pour les régionales quizz géant qu'est
vous cela parce que précisément je pense
que le mode de scrutin des départements
est un mode de scrutin scélérat
puisqu'il pris 25% des électeurs
français d'une représentation légitime
et que je sais parfaitement qu'au
dernier moment
l'ump et le ps se met ensemble appelle à
voter les uns pour les autres se désiste
bénéfice des uns au bénéfice des autres
et que donc il est imprévisible
il est très difficile de prévoir si vous
voulez le nombre de cantons qui peuvent
être gagnés ce qui est prévisible c'est
que l'ump s est de plus en plus
fusionner entre eux et que après tout
ils feraient bien de faire un parti
unique et puis comme ça au moins c'est à
dire que des régions sont gagnables vous
pensez que ça mobilise particulièrement
aux électeurs ça les incite à aller
non mais j'ai dit la vérité voilà ce
jeudi la réalité de ce qui est ces
régions sont gagnables
si je regarde les élections européennes
et si je regarde les élections
départementales étant entendu que les
réflexes de vote sont à mon avis plus
proche des européennes dans des
régionales que des départementales parce
qu'il ya beaucoup moins quand même deux
d'aspect locales dans des régionales
surtout dans les grandes régions
fusionner oui nous pouvons gagner un
certain nombre d'enjeux n'arrête pas de
parler de l'ump esma nicolas sarkozy a
été très ferme sur la doctrine d'une
ligne entre non travailleurs bombe alors
il faut quitter la tête de l'ump parce
que personne ne l'a écoutée
parce que dans la drôme parce que dans
nord pas de calais parce que dans la
meuse
parce qu'en moselle parce que anime tous
les ump ont appelé à voter ps
ils se sont même désister pour permettre
l'élection du est de 2,2 socialistes et
même parfois de communistes comme ça a
été le cas à perpignan les ump appelant
à voter communiste
alors arrêtons le cinéma jaune on
comprend pas bien dans une interview à
paraître à causeur vous dites que le mps
n'existe pas pour la présidentielle
alors ça existe à certaines élections et
à d'autres emplacements de la
présidentielle est une élection tout à
fait particulière où les étiquettes des
partis politiques ne rentre pas en ligne
de compte
ou c'est la personnalité des candidats
qui est importante c'est la rencontre
entre un homme ou une femme et le peuple
directement et donc je pense que
d'ailleurs vous imaginez bien on peut se
l'imaginer entre nous que des reports de
voix par exemple du parti socialiste ne
seraient pas les mêmes sur nicolas
sarkozy ou sur alain juppé il en joue
d'ailleurs l'un et l'autre donc on voit
bien que ce sont des ce septième ps
fonctionne évidemment moins bien ça veut
pas dire que le parti socialiste et
j'écoutais du second tour n'appellerait
pas à voter ump et vice versa c'est
exactement probablement ce qui se
passera mieux bien sûr mais bien sûr
parce qu'en fait ils ne survivent
concentré dans françois hollande
appelant à voter oui les sarkophiles
bien sûr mais bien sûr parce que il ne
sent il n'existe quant on s'entraide ans
l'un l'autre
en réalité si l'un disparaît l'autre
disparaît aussi florian philippot avez
raison de dire ce sont les inséparables
je veux dire quand l'un meurt l'autre
meurent aussi
et donc ses réflexes la leur permettent
de se maintenir néanmoins depuis des
années sans respecter la volonté du map
de l'un ou de l'autre lequel
préféreriez-vous à mesure comme
adversaire du second tour si vous y
parvenez mais j'ai pas préférant je
n'aurais pas je n'aurai pas une ligne a
changé de mon argumentaire contre là où
contre l'autre ils ont mené là serait
peut-être moins grande les ont mené la
même politique moi je fais de la
politique
ils ont mis les mêmes chiffres de
l'immigration les mêmes délires de du
laxisme en matière judiciaire
leleu le même la même politique
économique la même aussi dangereux que
vous que pour vous salaire salaire plus
simple en général pour le front national
face à un candidat de gauche par exemple
face à ces endroits regnam et de toute
façon on parle de rien laval embraseront
ne rien dire c'est pas nous qui décidons
c'est le peuple français qui décide donc
laissons la primaire ump s se dérouler
la primaire de la primaire ump s sortira
le candidat de l'ump est ce que candidat
du système qui arrivera au second tour
moi vous êtes sûrs d'être au second tour
assure n'est jamais sûr de rien je veux
dire je peux sortir demain de votre
studio il peut m'arriver n'importe quoi
écouter même pendant l'émission rire et
encore 20 minutes
bon en tout cas vous l'affirmez votre
objectif c'est l'elysée et pour parvenir
à l'elysée faut 50% plus une voix est
quelle est la stratégie que vous allez
développer pour ça sachant que toutes
les élections le monde que vous
progressez mais au deuxième tour scrutin
majoritaire à deux tours c'est quand
même compliqué toujours pour le front
national de se faire élire il faut c'est
compliqué mais enfin il ya des
augmentations spectaculaires entre les
deux ouvreurs mais là il ya des
augmentations depuis 2000 douze
personnes le conteste mais
départementale 1100 second tour 30-30
élections donc il ya encore sa soeur
généralise au niveau de l'afrique à tort
30 élection et vous avez vous même fait
le calcul
plus de 90 cantons où 99 je crois qu'en
tant qu'ils étaient entre 45 et 50 dont
22 qui était entre 48 et 50 bons donc
donc voilà non mais ça je pense qu'il
faut arrêter de vouloir absolument
intégrer des mathématiques dans la
politique la politique c'est autre chose
que des mathématiques
voilà c'est c'est à dire exactement la
même chose que ready qui l'a confirmé il
avec les français italiens charnel avec
dans les manuels valls il fait une
politique déplorable et les français
sont conscients que ce soit lui ou un
autre ce sera la même politique
déplorable car ils ont compris
précisément que ça n'est pas le
gouvernement qui décide que c'est madame
merkel qui décide voilà voilà ce qu'ils
ont compris les français donc faut donc
c'est un lien charnel entre le candidat
celui qui est celui qui aspire à
représenter le peuple français et le
peuple français et donc il n'y a pas de
logique mathématique qui rentrent en
ligne de compte d'autant que les dangers
qui pèsent sur notre pays sont de plus
en plus importants et ils vont continuer
à s'aggraver soient économiques et
sociaux du fait de la politique imposée
par l'union européenne soit sur le plan
de l'immigration car ce sujet vous avez
été évacués et volontairement
semble-t-il évacués du débat et pourtant
il est essentiel ce sont des centaines
de milliers de personnes qui cherchent
aujourd'hui à rejoindre l'union
européenne qui est une véritable
passoire la déstabilisation de la
tunisie qui est la conséquence des
erreurs politiques que nicolas sarkozy a
commis en libye
tout cela évidemment va continuer à
faire peser sur le pays
un poids qui va devenir au fur et à
mesure insupportable dernières
informations sur le troisième tour
départemental dans le vaucluse la gauche
ne va pas présenter de candidat exécutif
ça vous donne pas ça vous aura pas
l'occasion de voter pour la gauche a
émerveillé d'un voilà tient lui-même ps
regardez comme ils sont beaux à regarder
pour permettre l'élection de l'ump le
parti socialiste ne va pas présenter de
candidat il y aura peut-être une
contrepartie dans un autre département
dans qu'est ce que vous en pensez ne pas
me pas les gens pensaient que peut-être
vous auriez pu vous créez un peu du
trouble supplémentaires en votant pour
le candidat socialiste périodes moins
candidat nous nous avons un candidat
nous présentons un candidat à la
présidence du département
mais j'attends de voir quelle sera la
contrepartie de ce retrait du parti
socialiste bénéficie il ya de lieux de
nombreux pays de nombreux systèmes
politiques ou les partis font entre des
alliances c'est pas le diable que de
faire des alliances entre partis peu
d'entre eux partis qui sont adversaires
ils peuvent être adversaires et se
retrouver sur certaines politiques
ah oui non mais là il se retrouve avant
l'élection là quand même ah non moi des
adversaires qui se retrouvent ensemble
dans les lectures après l'élection avec
son mail
mais avant l'élection il se retrouve
voilà l'ump s ils se retrouvent avant
l'élection donc y'a quand même pas
beaucoup de système politique où les
adversaires se retrouvent avant
l'élection sauf en france
l'élection une raison simple c'est qu'en
réalité c'est une réelle opposition
monsieur dedans est factice voilà elle
est là pour amuser la galerie mais il
n'y a plus de différence entre la gauche
la droite depuis bien longtemps et vous
changeriez les étiquettes des gens qui
ont été élus vous n'y verrez que du
persil perrine tarneaud de public sénat
arrive maintenant
marine le pen nous allons évoquer votre
programme donc différent totalement
différent de vos adversaires l'ump et le
ps avec vos solutions miracles qui nous
mènerait selon ne soyez pas mais présent
c'est pas mépriser solution miracle il
n'y a pas de miracle
c'est beau solution miracle j'allais
dire je vais bien sa politique savait
faire un mot des solutions miracles qui
s'apparente à un cauchemar pour certains
économistes et vos adversaires alors
êtes vous sûrs d'avoir d'avoir choisi le
bon positionnement politique d'ailleurs
la question et relance ripon choisi
l'asie à positionnement politique on
défend pas ses convictions et relancions
vous fréquentez trop souvent du mps vaut
la question est relancé après le second
tour départemental vous allez voir on va
en parler avec perrine dans un instant
d'abord la présentation de vos mesures à
pékin passant la caricature avec sandra
cerqueira et vous allez voir il ya des
personnes vont conseiller économique du
fn qui parle dans le sujet dakar marine
le pen a un objectif le pouvoir et pour
l'atteindre
elle met en avant depuis 2012 l'économie
et le social pour tenter de gagner en
crédibilité au coeur de son programme
la sortie de l'euro le conseiller
économique de marine le pen la sueur
d'évaluer notre monnaie permettra de
retrouver la compétitivité
si on baisse de 25% l'autre mon avis
l'allemagne
immédiatement toutes les peugeot et
renault vont vendre comme des petits
pains en europe puisqu'elles seront 25 %
moins cher comparativement que
volkswagen pour beaucoup d'experts
marine le pen promet la lune passer au
nouveau franc ne ferait qu'ajouter des
difficultés à une économie française
déjà morose une situation explosive au
niveau de l'endettement une méfiance
très importante à l'égard de la dette
française une augmentation des taux
d'intérêts internationaux avec lesquels
on peut refinancer notre dette donc là
effectivement ce sont des engagements
qui sont très très lourd est intenable
autre mesure économique du front
national augmenter les salaires
un coup de pouce de 200 euros nets à
tous les salariés touchant moins de 1500
euros
c'est pas qu'on va donner on va
augmenter le smic c'est qui va augmenter
parce qu'on à baisser les cotisations
payées par les salariés
les cotisations salariales alors ça
coûte quelques milliards mais ça sera
compensée par justement une taxe de 3%
sur les produits importés
sept économistes dénoncent une mesure
démagogique qui coûterait 20 milliards
d'euros et plomberait la compétitivité
des entreprises
toutefois qu'il ya une forme de paradoxe
d'un côté de dire je veux défendre le
pouvoir d'achat des salariés je commente
le salaire est au même moment je vais
tasse en dévalant et en est en place et
doit d'avoir
mais je crois que le programme du front
national est remplie en réalité de
contradictions des contradictions qui
pourrait nuire à la crédibilité du
programme est détourné du fn une partie
de son électorat comme les artisans et
les petits entrepreneurs
effrayé par un protectionnisme à
outrance voilà un sujet qui a fait
bouillir marine le pen est ce que votre
programme économique ne déroute pas des
électeurs potentiels qui doutent de sa
faisabilité
dans ce qui déroute c'est les mensonges
que leur déverse ses pseudos experts qui
sont en réalité des fumistes je vous dis
gentiment mais clairement voilà
quelqu'un qui vient dire que la
proposition que nous faisons de faire
prendre en charge par l'état 200 euros
de la part salariale des cotisations
sociales plomberait la compétitivité des
entreprises et par quel bout
appelons leurs comptes pourquoi
supplémentaires à baudelaire ceux pris
par l'êta près par l'état oui c'est ça
donc ça coûte des milliards et les 20
milliards ils sont financés par une
contribution sociale à la place de
surprise non mr sarr et peuvent avoir un
meilleur si vous voulez de se retrouver
avec des salaires trop élevés est ce que
dans ta maman avoir un bon mix est
plutôt rythme ils vont avoir en charge
de voir leur famille car avoir 200 euros
de plus qu elles n'auront pas payé et
qui ne comme bruno bini entament a pas
les moyens si vous voulez d'offrir ces
200 euros nets par mois maintenant des
salariés moi on va s'arrêter là tout de
quoi vous parlez là l'étape et moins de
quoi je vous dis que cette mesure est
financé d'accord bon pendant que l'état
n'est pas un scoop mais tous les ans
elle est financée par une contribution
sociale à l'importation de 3%
voyez je vais vous dire je vais
commencer par dénoncer de la manière la
plus ferme et la plus officielle la
manière dont nous sommes traités sur les
plateaux de télévision et par ce genre
d'experts on raconte n'importe quoi par
n'importe quoi aux français aux
caricatures le programme du front
national on ne sait même pas de quoi on
parle car on l'a général n'aiment pas lu
ce monsieur là il l'a même pas lui lui
croit qu'on va augmenter de 200 euros le
smic
ce qui évidemment est une mauvaise
mesure car ça entraînerait une prise en
charge par les entreprises qui n'en
peuvent plus de d'une charge qui serait
insupportable pour elle
voyez le le le là la mauvaise foi ses
coups de lame au ce de l'incompétence
des possibilités mais l'engagement du
film vous venez de me dire vous venez me
dire c'est financé pour combien de temps
donc vous n'avez pas lu vous n'avez pas
lu que nous voulons mettre en place une
contribution sociale à l'importation de
3 % sur les produits importés qui donc
évidemment arrive tous les ans que
figurez-vous bien mais les produits
importés qui arrivent tous les airs sur
le pouvoir d'achat du coup de manière
est dérisoire mais ça augmente les prix
de manière dérisoire par rapport par
rapport aux 200 euros que vont pouvoir
obtenir les salaires les plus faire de
manière dérisoire
toujours est il qu'il ya peut-être un
électorat de droite qui est un petit peu
déroutés par votre programme économique
et qui ne vous suis pas notamment sur la
partie très étatiste et
interventionniste
mais si vous visionnez les efforts des
nationalisations par exemple non mais
c'est ça non mais madame c'est pareil
bon là aussi on est dans la caricature
la plus totale
explique marine le pen et comme
mélenchon à la nationaliser tout non
j'ai évidemment sa magie des dents mais
c'est ce que dit ma raison monsieur
gattaz qui est censé être lui aussi un
grand ponte un grand patron il raconte
n'importe quoi
il a dû encore bien votre programme
d'ailleurs je remarque que je lui ai
lancé la proposition d'un débat mais on
préfère caricaturer et l'a reprogrammé à
proposer voilà dans le challenge plutôt
que de venir débattre avec marine le pen
on pourrait éventuellement vous êtes
bien être gêné être gêné d'être obligé
de montrer soit qu'on maîtrise pas ce
dont on parle
soit qu'on ne connaît absolument pas le
programme du front national la
nationalisation temporaire des banques
elle ne doit s'effectuer que si les
banques sont en très grave
la difficulté mais dites moi ça n'est
pas ce qu'a fait la grande bretagne est
ce que la grande bretagne est considéré
comme un pays d'extrême gauche
je ne crois pas c'est un pays libéral
mais bon mais n'a pas nationalisées bien
sûr que si mais bien sûr que si madame
bien sûr que si elle a nationalisé les
banques voilà
et pourtant cet appel libéral mais à un
moment donné quand on voit que des
banques sont en train de tomber
mieux vaut les nationaliser de manière
temporaire pour préserver évidemment
l'intérêt des déposants
plutôt que de voir la situation échapper
au contrôle de l'état stratège l'état
stratège c'est du de gaulle je veux dire
faut pas moi je veux bien que ça effraie
les gens de droite mais moi je crois que
ce qui les effraie c'est la caricature
qu'on donne de notre programme pas la
réalité
vous n'envisagez pas du tout de corriger
votre approche économique ni votre
projet économique mais non parce que
j'ai moi j'ai des convictions je crois
ce que je défends et donc je ne vais pas
changer mes propositions au motif qu
untel ou untel serait inquiet c'est en
général c'est une partie comme le disait
perrine peut-être des électeurs de
droite ont laissé moins terminer la
phrase est ce que je vais donc faire je
vais faire de la pédagogie
je vais venir dénoncer merci de
motoriser de le faire tous les encore
une fois les pseudos experts tous les
fumistes qui viennent raconter n'importe
quoi c'est au programme du front
national et ça prendra du temps et bien
ça prendra le temps qu'il faut alors
voilà
vos prises de position et vous comptez
les martelé elle assure la sortie de
l'euro regarder quand même un peu ce qui
se passe en grèce et une crainte de
sortie de l'euro en grèce qui fait que
les clients des banques vis de leur
compte 30 milliards d'euros se sont
évaporés est ce que ça voudrait dire
qu'il a contrario l'euro rassurant tout
non mais c'est pas le sait pas la
centaine d'euros qui fait peur à ceux
qui retirent leur argent c'est la
situation de la grèce depuis des depuis
des années maintenant je t'attends ces 5
partis de laura mais rapidement les
médias tenter de redresser des comptes
ça fait cinq ans que ça dure voilà la
sortie de la grèce de l'euro
n'entraînera pas la chute de l'euro la
sortie de la france de l'euro entraînera
la disparition de l'euro la situation
est radicalement différente mais ça
aussi c'est un argument que j'ai entendu
dans la bouche notamment de m sortir de
l'euro notamment notamment de monsieur
gata alem si on serait les salles à
partir de l'euro de la zone euro mais
ont semé se sont même si on était sortie
de la zone euro y aurait plus de roue
voilà c'est comme ça parce que la france
est un pivot essentiel du fonctionnement
de l'euro bon par l'autre fumiste de il
ya tout à l'heure ça va exploser les
économistes faut voir ce sont souvent
les gens qu'à domicile ce conteneur
patenté mais en demies ou parce que
souvent ce sont surtout des emplois il
donc car ce sont des consultants payés
par des banques
il est toujours intéressant de savoir
qui parle et d'où ils parlent et moi je
m'attache à saïx croyez moi on a des
shows alors revenir vite il nous dit ça
va entraîner une explosion de
l'endettement la dévaluation c'est ça
qu'ils disent beaucoup d'échos de la
coop énorme alors très simplement la
dette at-elle explosé là depuis trois
mois on parle de la sortie de la zone
nord n'annoncez pas
il parle de la dévaluation est ce que la
dette a explosé depuis trois mois oui
non non donc ça aussi c'était un
mensonge
l'euro a été dévalué de 25% que ce soit
l'euro le franc ou vous l'appelez
n'importe comment
la dévaluation de la monnaie la hausse
des taux d'intérêt la déveine pas
obligatoirement la dévaluation de 25% de
la monnaie n'a entraîné aucune explosion
de la dette
permettez moi quand même un petit tacle
à nicolas sarkozy grand économiste
devant l'éternel lui aussi qui nous
avait expliqué qu'une dévaluation de la
monnaie entraînerait le doublement ou à
un triplement de la dette c'est-à-dire
4000 milliards ou 6000 milliards
évaluation c'est une modification du
cours
le sait c'est que ça fait la même chose
c'est exactement excusez-moi j'ai écouté
on va pas faire un débat pour moi ou je
ne sais pas baisser la garde
c'est une grande et valu l'affront pour
rembourser une dette en euros c'est sûr
que ça va maintenant
mais ce bond conclusions parce que la
dette ne reste à entendre en euro cher
monsieur car il y a une règle
fondamentale en économie qui est
appliquée par tous les pays du monde
s'appelle l'alecso détails
c'est à dire que à partir du moment où
un pays change de monnaie la dette est
libellée dans la nouvelle monnaie du
pays
donc si 1 euro égale un nouveau franc
est bien la dette ne bougera pas sauf
103% qui est si et qui est contracté
contrats étrangers 3 % de la dette c'est
quand même en sorte de tout naturel et
économique
oui avec une enquête ouverte par le
parquet de paris sur des soupçons
d'irrégularités dans l'emploi et la
rémunération des assistants d europe et
d eurodéputés pardon du front national
après un signalement du parlement
européen alors les soupçons portent sur
les salaires versés à ces vins assistant
qui apparaissent dans l'organigramme
aussi du front national ce qui laisse
supposer qu'ils sont affectés à d'autres
tâches alors qu'ils sont payés par le
parlement européen
vous n'êtes donc pas en régularité avec
les instances est tout à fait en
régularité
nous sommes là confronté je le dénonce
de la manière la plus claire qui soit à
une opération politique
voilà c'est une opération politique
organisé par monsieur schulz embrayé par
madame taubira et nous n'avons
strictement rien à nous reprocher vous
imaginez un instant à la fois nommés par
le parlement européen il ne travaille
pas pour le front national
ils ont des responsabilités des
fonctions politiques au front national
mais dites moi monsieur delapierre
l'assistant parlementaire monsieur
mélenchon il n'a pas des fonctions
politiques aussi est ce qu'il n'ya pas
dans tous les partis politiques des gens
qui ont des seins travail et des
fonctions politiques mais le pilote
d'air france par exemple qui est
conseiller au transport aérien mais ton
est ce que on peut lui reprocher d'avoir
un travail et une fonction de conseiller
fois tout ça n'a aucun sens
l'objectif encore une fois est un
objectif politique et je suis très
étonné mais c'est la démonstration de
l'opération politique évidemment que
monsieur chose s'est saisi le parquet
pourquoi saisir le parquet alors que
l'olaf l'organisation de lutte contre la
fraude
a été saisie normalement c'est lola qui
fait son enquête et qui saisit le
parquet s'il y a des irrégularités la
manière dont monsieur schulz à ce quizz
et l'olap en saisissant sa copine madame
taubira
ces montants à l'évidence à l'évidence
la manipulation politique dans ce
dossier très bien une petite terreur
question il reste quelques secondes
demain la production de lait dans
l'union européenne va cesser d'être
limité c'est la fin de trente ans de
quotas et là on voit apparemment les
producteurs français ne s'inquiète pas
trop ici si ce n'est pas moi je voulais
les voir ils n'ont pas peur des grands
vents de la mondialisation manifestement
ils y trouvent des opportunités on
attend dé vous avez discuté avec qui
excusez moi est vrai que patron de la
commission attendait avec le patronat on
est on est forts de nos grandes savait
que tous les autres crèvent mes écoutes
et arrêtés on est au devant d'une crise
extrêmement grave du lait à cause de la
fin des quotas
il faut écouter les éleveurs ils sont
extrêmement inquiets par la fin des
quotas bien entendu bon voilà certains y
voient comme des opportunités mais c'est
ça le patron de lactalis y voit surtout
une opportunité voilà merci merci à tous
bon soir à bientôt